I'm I'm I'm translating it myself so it
might not be exactly accurate.
>> I can bring up so you're going to say
you Christians butcher the Bible and you
mistransate. Yeah, I've heard that too.
>> All right. But yeah, I'll open up for
everyone to see so we can see. I I'll
read it for Kabat for you. Hold on.
>> Okay.
>> Because I don't want Oh, yeah. You
Christians, you you guys, you know, you
idoltors, you pagans, that's why we
don't go to your church and you worship
three. I know. I've heard it. Yeah.
Okay. I know. I know. I've I've gotten
the memo. You pagans, we won't go to a
church, but we'll enter a mosque because
the Muslims worship the same God. Okay.
Yeah, I've heard that, too. All right,
let's go here. Zechariah.
Yeah. Yeah. That's why you know your
Jesus is burning and boiling.
Here it is. Uh Zechariah 3.
>> Uh Sam,
>> yeah.
>> Just about the point about Jesus
burning. I never say it. I know the
Talmud says it, but
>> I know you didn't say it. I know. I know
that.
>> Right. Right. But but the way I see it
is about that point just for one second
that
>> the Christian Bible talks about the Jews
very very badly.
>> That's not true.
>> So it's called the synagogue of Satan.
>> Okay. Jewish apologetics. Your prophet
said worse about you. Isaiah called you
Sodom and Gomorra and Ezekiel said
you're worse than Sodom.
>> No problem. So when the Jews
>> Oh, no problem. When your prophet says
it, but when Jesus the Jew and other
Jews say that about you now it's
anti-Semitic. Come on, man.
>> No, I did not say it's it is. I'm just
trying to explain. Is Isaiah wicked and
evil for saying you are worse or you are
Sodom and Gomorra? And is Ezekiel 16,
Ezekiel worse than the New Testament? It
says you're worse than Sodom and
Gomorrah.
>> No, let's say it's true, right? Let's
say the the New Testament is true.
>> Wait, wait, it is true. I'll bring you
there. Ezekiel 16, it says, "You are so
wicked, you make Sodom blush."
>> 100%. I'm just trying to make the
>> Is he evil for calling you that? No, I
did not think this is evil for calling.
>> No, I know. Let me make my point because
you false um analogy with the New
Testament. The New Testament doesn't say
every Jew is of Satan because then John
the Jew who wrote that means he's saying
he's of Satan.
John who told you you Jews who reject
Jesus are synagogue, he's a Jew. The
first followers of Jesus are Jewish. We
believe the greatest creature is a
Jewish woman. So don't play that game
with me. We believe Miam whom you call
the greatest woman that God created and
she's a Jewish woman. Don't play that
game because your Old Testament is
worse. Isaiah said you're Sodom and
Gomorrah. Is he wicked?
>> No.
>> All right, let's not go there.
>> All right. So, can I can I respond?
>> Does your atonement say Miriam is
>> I think so. I didn't really I think so.
>> Does your atonement say Jesus is burning
and boiling?
>> Correct. But can I respond? respond to
what you say. What you say
>> to the point you made?
>> No, no, to the point you made to put to
the point you made. Can I respond?
>> Go ahead.
>> Okay. So, the basically Yeah. Okay. I
agree to the point you're trying to say
that it's not evil that they said it.
But I'm seeing it from the lens of these
people that lived back then. They wrote
the Talmud. They were being persecuted
by Christians and Christians used to
call them sing of Satan. They say,
"Okay, we are synphet
is so and so." Right? Whatever they
said. That was like a response.
So what about before Christians
persecuted the Jews when they didn't
have imperial force for example origin
writing in the second third century to a
Greek pagan opponent of Christianity
Celus who said he was taught by the Jews
that Mary was who was persecuting the
Jews to say that about her in the second
and third century.
>> Okay. Yeah. So I agree the Jews were at
fault as well. I'm not saying the Jews
were at fault. I'm talking about
>> listen what you said.
>> Be patient. I'm answering you but you're
not listening. You said when the tommet
is codified in the fifth and sixth
centuries because they were being
persecuted. Well, in the second to third
centuries when the Christians were being
by the Roman Empire, being either
crucified or
or fed to lions, Celus, a Greek pagan to
mock Greeks converting Christianity,
said that according to the Jews that he
learned from, Mary was who got pregnant
by a Roman soldier. So who is
persecuting the Jews to teach the pagans
that when the Christians were not in
power?
>> You talking about the the second
century?
>> Yeah. Second, third century Christians
in that power.
>> Who was persecuting? It was whoever who
was in control of the Romans, I think.
I'm not sure.
>> But that wasn't the Christians. You just
Brother, you're not listening to
yourself. See, this is what's killing.
>> No, I agree. It wasn't the Christians
back then. Okay.
>> But you just the fifth century. It was
the Christians.
>> But brother, you were already saying it
in the second century.
No, I refer to the fifth century when
the Talmud was written. Fifth, sixth
century.
>> Splash my head. The tool is reflecting
earlier tradition. Correct.
>> Not only.
>> Okay. Second century Jews. My goodness.
The Jews were already saying Mary's got
knocked up by a Roman and it found its
way in the Tmud. So don't blame what the
tommet says about Mary because
Christians are persecuting them because
the Jews were already saying this about
Mary in the second century when no
Christian harmed them.
>> The Christians were were as well as the
Jews were snitching to the government.
They were doing it to each other. I'm
not saying anyone to blame Zechariah 3.
Go ahead.
>> Okay, let's go back. Okay. Zechariah 3.
Which which verse?
>> Verses three and four.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay, it says Joshua was
wearing filthy garments and standing
before the angel. And then it says he
said to the standing to the people, not
people, it says to whoever was standing
plural in front of him, uh, take off the
gar filthy garment from him. And then he
says, look, I uh took off of you your
iniquities and put upon you. I don't
know how to translate the last word
here.
>> All right. Anyway, let me read it for
you. Here's the kabad.org,
guys. This is the Tanakans by Orthodox
Jews, not Christians.
>> Yeah. Just Sam, before you start, I have
just a few more minutes, so we'll try to
finish. We'll end here. We'll end and
I'll send you my email if you want to
come back, talk more. But here, now
Joshua was wearing filthy garments,
standing before the angel. Now, do you
see Kabad put the word angel in
brackets?
>> Yeah,
>> I didn't do that. Right.
>> Right.
>> And the angel raised his voice and said
to those standing before him, saying,
"Take the filthy filthy garments out of
him." So who commanded the others to
take the garments off?
>> Right? The angel. But I'm just confused
here because he's saying to those
plurality, who those
>> angels that are there? Remember what I
told you in the beginning in Zechariah?
There's a group of angels. You remember?
You forgot that point.
>> I forgot. It was a long time ago. We
went through so many. So which which
chapter was the
>> in chapter one? And you read two, three,
and four and five and six.
>> The angel of Hashem is surrounded by
other angels that are serving him.
>> Okay,
>> let's read the book. It's there. But the
point is who is telling them to remove
the filthy garments?
>> The angel of the Lord.
>> Buddy, now can you explain to me why the
angel said, "See, I have removed your
iniquity from you." How does the angel
take away his sins?
>> Right. So, there's two points I can make
here.
>> Okay. Go ahead.
>> You want to hear?
>> No, I'm going to hear. Yeah. Yeah.
Because Okay. Two points. One of it is
that the angel represents God. So, when
he speaks, he speaks in God's name.
Secondly,
Secondly, Yeah. Yeah. Secondly, uh what
would what I want to say?
>> Yeah. Go ahead. Secondly, you want
>> Secondly, okay.
>> What?
>> Go ahead. Secondly, it's Exodus 23. I
just you just prove my point. God said,
"My name is in him, which is why he can
forgive sins. He will not forgive your
sins, which means he has the power to
forgive." So, we're back to my point
again. Exodus 23:21. You see how it
works now,
>> right? So, so God can give him the power
to forgive sins, right?
>> Okay.
>> I'm not saying that does not prove that
he's God. But I'm saying God could give
some other power just like
>> if you want to say God can well and then
you're getting closer to the early
church that the son was begotten of the
father. So that the father's essence and
the father's name are also the son's
essence and the son's name because he's
begotten of the father. So now you're
closer to the trinity when you going to
get baptized
>> again. So I didn't get that last point.
So you're saying the son is the father.
Absolutely.
>> Even No, no, no. Even if I agree with
you, the father gives to this angel his
divine prerogatives and abilities. Even
though Exodus 23 says, "My name is
already in him." Doesn't say he gave it
to him at some point. You're now closer
to what the church teaches historically,
the son begotten of the father. Meaning
like begets like, right? Kind begets
kind. So the son, if his father is God
and he's begotten of him, he's going to
have his nature and authority. So now
you're closer to the truth. When are you
going to get baptized?
>> No, not yet. Not that fast.
>> Sorry. So that you're still not making
your case. You made my case because we
now came back full circle. The angels
>> just go ahead.
>> Yeah. Just one point. So you're saying
here when he speaks to plurality of
people to take off the garments, it's
speaking to the angels that were with
him in chapter one.
>> Yes. But that's okay. Even let's whoever
it is.
>> Does the verse say see I I singular I
removed your iniquity from you?
>> Yeah.
>> That means the angel does what God does.
Joshua 24:19,
>> right? But does that prove that it's God
or it could be that God gave him the
authority to do so?
>> Who can forgive sins but God alone?
>> Okay. So, for example,
>> right? Yeah.
>> Yeah. We we we touched about it. If you
don't want to talk to because it's not
the Old Testament, we could not. Yeah.
So, in the New Testament, it speaks
about uh the fact that Jesus gave the
disciples
the authority to
>> Okay, let let me go to that text because
you keep
>> Can you open it because I don't have it
open, but you can open it on your
screen.
>> It didn't prove your case because I want
to show you how they forgive. Okay,
let's go there. Let's go because you
keep mentioning this. All right, let's
go right here. John 20:21. Okay, John
20:21-31. So Jesus said to them again,
"Peace be with you. As the father has
sent me, I also send you." When he said
said this, he breathed on them and said
to them, "Receive the Holy Spirit." Now
according to the Tanakh,
does anyone besides God breathe out the
Holy Spirit?
>> Uh no.
>> So right there, Jesus does what God
does. He breathed out the Holy Spirit.
Pay attention. And when he had said
this, he breathed on them and said to
them, "Receive the Holy Spirit." So the
very chapter you're quoting shows you
Jesus is the God who authorizes them to
forgive sins in his name. I'll get
there. If you forgive the sins of any,
their sins have been forgiven them. If
you retain the sins of any, they have
been retained. Now, how do they forgive
sins? Let's now go to the chapter
itself. John 20 30-31. Therefore, many
other signs Jesus also did in the
presence of the disciples which are not
written in this book. But these have
been written so that you may believe
that Jesus is the Christ, the son of
God, and that believing you may have
life in his name. You see how they
pronounce forgiveness and salvation?
>> In his name.
>> Thank you. Now, did the angel say,
"Hashem forgive you?"
>> No.
>> They said, "In the name of Jesus Christ,
you'll be forgiven."
>> Oh, so you agree they could have the
power to forgive as long as they say
it's in the name of of Jesus.
>> They have the power. They have the
authority to proclaim you turn to
Christ, you're forgiven.
Let me show you now that that that's how
they did it. Here, Acts 2 37 38. They
only forgave not by saying, "I forgive
you. Jesus has commanded us that if you
believe in him and get baptized in him,
you are forgiven. You'll be given the
Holy Spirit." Here, I'm not making up.
Acts 237:38. Now when they heard this,
they were pierced to the heart and said
to Peter and the rest of the apostles,
"Men, brothers, what should we do?"
Peter said to them, "Repent and each of
you be baptized in the name of Jesus
Christ for the forgiveness of your
sins." Now, can you show me a single
verse in the Hebrew Bible where prophet
said, "Repent and be baptized in the
name of Moshe, so you'll be forgiven
your sins and receive the gift of the
Holy Spirit."
>> Uh, I don't know the whole Old
Testament, but not that I can think of.
Let me show you what the Old Testament
says. The Hebrew Bible says, you know
whose name forgives? Watch here because
I know if you want to look at it, you
can. Psalm 25:11. I'll have it on the
screen. Let me go to kabad. Well, yeah,
because then it'll be too long. Well,
let me go
>> and we'll finish with this point, okay?
Because I got to go
>> because Yeah, don't go yet because I
want to show you. Uh, let me go to
kabad.org.
In the Hebrew Bible, the only name that
forgives sins is the name of Hashem, the
name of
Elohim. I said keohim. It's Elohim. You
guys pronounce it Elohim. All right.
Now, let me just show you real quickly
before you leave. Few minutes. We're
going to go to No, not all right. All
right. Let's go here. Psalm 25:11.
It may be different verse, but it's the
same chapter here. Remember what they
said? In the name of Jesus Christ, you
will give be given life and be forgiven,
right?
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. For your name's sake,
oh Lord, you shall forgive my iniquity
for it is great. So in according to
whose name forgives
>> uh God.
>> Oh yet New Testament says Jesus because
to them he was the God of Israel who
became flesh. Let me give you a few
more. Psalm
>> I agree that the New Testaments believe
that Jesus.
>> Can you show me where the angel like the
apostle said Hashem forgives you? In the
name of Hashem, you're forgiven.
>> No, he does not say that.
>> He forgives, right?
>> Correct.
>> Exactly. Psalm 54:1, "Oh God, with your
name, save me and with your might,
avenge me." It's only God's name. But
the angel did not say like the apostles,
"Believe in Hashem and you'll be
forgiven. In the name of Hashem, you're
forgiven." No, I forgive your sins.
So when you keep going to the apostles,
that doesn't help your case. Final one.
Psalm 79:9. Psalm 79:9.
Help us, oh God, of our salvation on
account of the glory of your name, and
save us and atone for our sins for your
name's sake.
Now, one more time, I want you to repeat
it because I want music to my ears. Did
the angel ever say, "In the name of
Hashem, you're forgiven. Hashem forgives
you."
>> No.
>> Did he say, "I forgive your sins?"
>> Yes. And did the apostles say, "In the
name of Jesus, you're forgiven?"
>> Yes.
>> Did they say, "I, Peter, forgive your
sins?"
>> Wait, I didn't hear the last uh part.
>> Did they say Did Peter say, "I, Peter,
forgive your sins?"
>> No.
>> Thank you. So, you prove two things
which you agree. New Testament show
Jesus is a God of Israel. And now you
prove the angel is not forgiving sins
like the apostles. He does what only God
does. He says, "I forgive you." Which is
something only God can do. So, when are
you going to get baptized? The Eastern
Orthodox are waiting for you.
Anyway, here's my email if you want to
talk more.
>> If you want to let me know it's you
because you were very respectful. I
appreciate it. I'm old, so bear with me,
but let me get you the email. Let me
know it's you. We can talk more. Here it
is. And then I got to go